do you know the top one percent earners
in America like top one percent the last
person on that list makes four hundred
forty thousand dollars a year yet
everyone has got a complete misnomer of
how this is people don't even talk about
anything less than making a million a
year that's the entry to kind of
something I'm like [__] you know
how few [__] people do that in their
life
your first half of it too
of course
oh when they started getting hella bread
Because the Internet didn't exist and
they used to take more time
I wish you kids [__] knew bro if I
had the internet I'd own the Jets and
the Knicks by now
speed in which you guys can do [__]
Prince [__] swept the [__] Studios
floor in exchange for studio time this
[__] [__]